How would you characterize,
or describe your own world view?
I would call myself a social democrat.
I think that is my commitment.
I was brought up in a social democratic family,
and I go on with this.
Social democracy has obviously some liberal ideas.
But if you ask me in general terms to describe
I would say that I'm a social democrat.
But there isn't much social democracy any more.
No, what we see is that the hay day of social democracy was after the war.
Those were really the most successful years.
I think that what we see now is..
a decline of the organized labour.
Because of the nature of the industries
the globalization, and so on.
200 million people joined the work force in countries that weren't integrated in the global work force.
And we are now in the midst of changes.
So social democracy is challenged,
both by the neoliberals
and by the people on the far left.
I still think that the only sensible
world view in social terms
is social democracy
Scandinavia and the Netherlands, when it was a social democracy, those are the places to look at.
Why is there this ongoing struggle
for mankind to create a just society?
Because a just society is a good thing,
so you try to bring in..
I mean, I see all the reasons to bring a just society.
But why is it so difficult to succeed?
Because there are people who lose
by having a just society.
Many people, powerful people will lose a great deal
if there is a just society.
The point is, are there enough people
interested in justice.
That's the problem. Just the reverse:
Why injustice? That's very easy to explain.
Why justice? is hard to explain.
Why would people be motivated to
bring about justice?
Enough people. And that's very hard,
actually you don't have enough people
Why not?
Power is dispersed. To concentrate power is very hard.
And when you concentrate power
you gain lots of things that you don't
like to share with others.
So the people that gain power, usually create
oligarchies of some kind
And what used to be called
'the iron law of the oligarchy'
I think there's a great deal to save from it,
and that's actually what you save in egalitarian
parties and egalitarian ideologies.
Once they've got the power, their commitment is gone
the privilege is there, the power is there,
why to share it with others?